you know normally these videos would be
a lot more polished I'll even give a
[ __ ] I'm gonna care if his videos not
polished or not because the Fox Disney
deal went through America do not I'm so
excited right now oh my god I do the Fox
dizzy deal okay um man do there's so
much stuff they could do now dude
there's so many things I could do okay
okay okay calm down calm down
calm down all right man we're home okay
so the deal goes through it deals
through this means that like like Disney
owns do Disney wants Disney owns Fox of
the fandom and they do they only X been
fantastic work okay here's the question
you suppose everybody wants to know
whose course you might want to know how
do you rule the xmin over into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that's the one
thing I want to see Wolverine son
America dude I can't do Wolverine man
Wolverine in this manner in this thing
okay and honestly there's a whole bunch
of different ways I can do this I think
they'll do the ultimate universe way of
bringing Wolverine in right like I think
it's the most reasonable way like like
do the ultimate universe version and
bring Wolverine in that way okay those
you guys who don't know really don't
know the ultimate universe way so here's
how the ultimate universe works so the
ultimate universe is a whole lot more
grounded right like the entirety of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is basically
the ultimate universe of Marvel Comics
the only difference here is like like
one or two things right ladies the only
real difference here is that you have
like Steve Rogers being the original
Super Soldier you have things like like
that basically being the only difference
um I guess that's the best essentially
it 2/3 man like okay okay so check this
out so so here's here's a chronology
like let's take mutants for example
here's a chronology of mutants in Marvel
Comics right I'm sorry in the alternate
universe this is this is what you bring
Wolverine in so the way this whole thing
happened is you had Captain America
Steve Nam so you'd have canary Steve
Robbie you had a Nick Fury who was the
original super soldier and then after
Nick Fury America created they had
project rebirth and they created Captain
America and then after the created
Captain America World War two ended
Captain America was frozen eyes well
yeah so anyway so Captain America's
frozen eyes just joined captain's circle
yo cap circle and so from there like the
the various like these various countries
in the world are just like we have to
launch our own super soldier program
right like we have to create our own
supers
program so they start trading like all
these different super soldiers and you
know all over the place well in the main
Marvel Universe Wolverine was created
out of a joint venture between canada's
department a department h i want to say
his canada's department h i want to say
department k is where you got the Alpha
Flight Vindicator all those guys sound a
sasquatch puck like all those all those
characters but uh but anyway was it was
one of Canada's like super black ops
organizations and the CIA in the United
States and in the main mobile universe
Wolverine was just a guy named Logan who
was part of Team X he was he was
basically a black ops of wet work guy
that's really all it was like they went
they went like underground I mean it was
it was gotta burn more correctly team X
was originally maverick Sabretooth
Wolverine and Silver Fox I think and the
whole idea was that Wolverine and
Sabretooth had healing factors and so
they gave the healing factors of
Sabretooth in Wolverine I believe to
Silver Fox and maverick
but anyway so so team axe is basically
co-opted by the CIA right they're like
okay so like we're gonna turn Team X
into like we're basically hand them over
and make them part of Weapon X the 10th
iteration of the weapons Plus program
weapon one being Captain America and so
the result of this is that we're gonna
come over you know or the Ultimate
Universe here in a second but the result
of this is that Wolverine is subjected
to the adamantium project he has
adamantium bought into his bones
Sabretooth is given adamantium and
Silver Fox in maverick no I think Silver
Fox in maverick got the healing factors
of Wolverine but I don't think they got
that thing they got out of mantium um
but anyway so what is it happening is
they they go forward Wolverine breaks
free yadda yadda yadda and then you get
X 23 you get Deadpool hold on alright
Ultimate Universe is totally different
because of the fact that Captain America
had basically been was perceived to have
been dead because everybody believed
that he was gone he was out of the
picture what they ended up doing was
they ended up taking the healing fee I'm
sorry they ended up going through
creating all these super soldiers and
and Canada took Logan they took James
Howlett and turned him like I try to
make a super soldier out of him try to
make another Captain America but along
the way they discovered that there are a
subset of humans that have a gene and if
the gene is activated they'll get powers
and so that was the birth of mutants
because what humanity did is they
basically modify that gene they
activated the gene in Wolverine which
basically gave birth to his healing
factor and all that kind of stuff from
there they actually like synthesized a
chemical I'm pretty sure and dispersed
it around the world and then suddenly
people's mutant powers started waking up
and so it's basically like the ultimate
universe version of in humans which kind
of makes sense cuz he Inhumans sucks so
what is there happening is like mutants
start rising to power and these things
get totally dogs or things are totally
different
like like magneto is not like - like a
redeemed guy right like my everybody
loves Michael Fassbender magneto all
right what if I told you that you could
get a Michael Fassbender magneto who's
not even looking for redemption who's
not even like like hey I did some CD
things like I killed Kevin Bacon like
the I did some of some pretty some
pretty rough things but I'm trying to be
a good guy I'm trying to do the right
thing what if I told you you won't even
get that what if I told you you would
get like a Michael Fassbender magneto
who's just like everyone's gonna die
like like I'm killing everyone everyone
like you I'm like I'm because I can
because like I control the the magnetic
spectrum of the world I can reverse the
magnetic poles
dude he lifts Thor's hammer man in the
ultimate universe magneto looks awesome
man it looks awesome okay okay you can
stuff like Legion you get stuff like
like this shadow I'll do the magic mist
Shadow King in the mall soon right yes
let me tell you something man y'all saw
sandals
man y'all thought that was bad no taste
some man like one that knows Daniels is
a badass but like of all the things
anybody's ever done Thanos is like the
least like like Thanos has invaded earth
a couple times he's had the infinity all
in the Cosmic Cube but when you look at
like the grand the grand scheme of like
[ __ ] people have done in Marvel Comics
daddles is nothing that dude apocalypse
bit apocalypses that is an absolute
diamond dude oh my god dude oh [ __ ] man
apocalypse my office abacus let me tell
you something man I would man I would
pay good money to see like apocalypse
versus the Avengers and the x-men
Avengers vs. x-men
oh my god oh my god okay if engineers
man Avengers vs. x-men okay here's a
here's a cool thing those you guys who
don't know Avengers vs. x-men was this
2012
story I think it was there's like the
most clickbait story that any person
could have ever written so here's where
this whole thing happened alright so
when is it going on here is that Jean
Grey's been dead for a long time right
like Marvel killed off Jean Grey and
she's been dead for something like seven
years when Avengers vs. x-men happened
and the whole idea here was that you had
a girl named Hope Summers alright she
was like this mutant Messiah and the
idea was that when hope was first born
she would go on to leave one or two
paths either she would become like this
like insane
crazy powerful chick who initiates
what's called the six second war where
she annihilates like like a million
humans in six seconds and then it
basically kicks off like a Days of
Future past kind of scenario which is
essentially bishops future uh or she
would go on to become like this Messiah
basically what she ends up doing like
she basically forms generation hope the
twelve lights all these seven things
like she gets wrecked by strife oh my
god strife emotion that you strive for
the most of my dears strife is cables
evil clone from the future dude strife
is so Opie stripe shows up from the
future right he's kibbles clone dude we
got to get back on track
strife shows up from the future as
cables clone alright like dismantles the
x-men he's just like an you're done like
like do drugs he shuts off the powers of
Cyclops he shuts off the powers of Jean
Grey like he turns Hope Summers into a
bomb Hope Summers is a girl who can copy
the powers of anyone and like he just
seizes control of this check and he's
like now now like I'm I'm in charge of
you so like now I'm gonna make you
absorb my power which is more telepathic
and telekinetic energy you could
possibly handle and then I'm gonna send
you to the x-men to make you blow up
like a bomb dude it was the most ever
dude
so the way the way this whole thing
happens ways this way this whole thing
unfolds alright anyway some ways one
thing happens like like the future with
everything yeah so anyway so so Hope
Summers you know is is goes on and do
her whole thing and then the Phoenix
comes back right like now this comes out
of a story called ex sanction right
we're like like cable shows up from the
future he comes back to life somehow he
shows back up and he tells Cyclops look
the Avengers are gonna come for Hope
Summers because the like hope hope is
gonna get the Phoenix force and if she
gets the Phoenix force she's like
they're the Avengers were afraid she's
gonna kill everything like Jean Grey did
when she became in Dark Phoenix and
annihilated like a whole she destroyed
his star which wiped out an entire solar
system he killed like billions of people
and during the the Dark Phoenix saga so
so cables like you have to protect her
at all cost so sorry class is like okay
so he goes and grabs Hope Summers and
says you're staying here the Xavier
Institute you're never leaving so what
is up happening after that is like like
Iron Man and Captain America the
Avengers realize the Phoenix force is
coming back and no like awesome because
like like a thief man like the Phoenix
force comes back and somebody gets hit
dude man they're gonna destroy
everything so they're like okay the
Phoenix force is going after Hope
Summers
we have to go get help so the Avengers
show up on the doorstep of the x-men and
they're like give us Hope Summers and
the x-men are like nope and what follows
is one of the greatest battles ever did
you get like gambit versus Captain
America there's like all these amazing
fights like this it's it's so peace but
anyway so so so the whole thing holding
transpired recently DaVinci vs. x-men
and all I kind of get stuff but there's
so many things they can do oh my god
there's so many things no I do okay I
could tell you right now I could plan
out the next 20 years the Marvel Comics
won't even the theory videos that we did
like I could legitimately like like
legit for real or true plan out the next
20 years of Marvel Comics like just
based on the Avengers the x-men the
Fantastic Four
then I would do Jonathan Hickman
Fantastic Four Oh matter John dude the
war of the four cities dunno what do I
would do Jonathan Hickman Fantastic Four
like leave them the mad celestial the
Council of Reed Richards like just these
crate like this for this infinite number
of Reed Richards
what is it the the all the doctor dooms
that are like down in the in the bottom
of the labyrinth cuz they've all been
lobotomized do like Franklin man don't
Franklin R it all do Franklin Richards
man to me my god just those guys you
don't know there's like in Jonathan
Hitman's Fantastic Four Franklin
Richards the son of Reed Richards
resurrects Galactus from the dead and
turns him into his Herald it's like holy
[ __ ] Galactus was terrified of Franklin
Richards he was so scared like when
Richard it was like when Franklin
Richards powers reawaken Galactus grabs
Reed and they take off and like Galactus
goes to a planet to feed but he's like
Reed we need to talk about your son
because like your son's powers are back
man and that's a problem because your
son is as powerful as me like like he
could kill me like you could get the
Abraxas saga where Galactus dies and
then like Abraxas basically spreads
throughout the multiverse like a plague
killing allah killing like every there's
one point we have goliath idea bite
Abraxas who's killed every single
version of Galactus across the
multiverse did you could do the
beyonders you get man mom God they could
do so much stuff dude I'm so hyped I'm
so hyped I'm so I'm sorry if I'm so
excited people but it is a very exciting
time right now it is a very exciting
time to be a comic book fan because
things are wrong now anyway I figured I
would be out to celebrate with y'all and
I'll catch you all later peace